cal c'est dans dix jours que le
gouvernement jospin annoncera sa
décision sur le dossier air france mardi
le ministre des transports jean claude
gayssot a rencontré les personnels de
roissy son interview dans l'humanité
l'avait précédé il s'y opposait la
privatisation du transporteur philippe
visseyrias une poignée de main et des
sourires de circonstance mais l'ambiance
est tendue
paris monsieur ministre jean claude
gayssot et christian blanc
deux visions radicalement différentes de
l'avenir d'air france le ministre
communiste des transports le répète à
qui veut l'entendre pas question de
privatiser la compagnie aérienne j'ai
dit que j'étais pas pour le statu quo
pour la privatisation je crois qu'à
partir de là tout faire pour que
l'entreprise développe rayonne au plan
national ces propos inquiète christian
blanc arrivé à la tête de la compagnie
en 1993 dans le but de la redresser puis
de la privatiser il sait que ces projets
sont compromis est il contre attaque
on ne peut pas changer les stratégies
des entreprises
en fonction des circonstances
électorales les entreprises ont besoin
de durer dans l'action et le monde de la
politique et le monde de l'entreprise
n'obéit pas aux mêmes raisons et aux
mêmes termes et si en blanc souhaiterait
une privatisation par tiers un tiers des
actions pour l'état un tiers pour les
salariés et un tiers pour les compagnies
partenaires pour défendre son bilan
le président d'air france met en avant
les 211 millions de francs de bénéfices
réalisés cette année après 8 ans de
pertes
du côté syndical c'est la désunion force
ouvrière premier syndicat de
l'entreprise apporte de même à christian
blanc un soutien inattendu comme on est
favorable à la politique qui a été mis
en place
okanga autant garder celui qui a
contribué avec les personnels à mettre
cette politique en place donc à emmener
la compagnie vers la privatisation a
ramené la compagnie vers son
développement
ce soir jean claude gayssot a voulu
rencontrer les syndicats lui aussi
chacun cherche des alliés pour sortir de
l'impasse
tout le monde attend maintenant
l'arbitrage de lionel jospin il pourrait
se prononcer avant le conseil
d'administration d'air france du 12
septembre